الكريم الذي يعلق على معلومات حول مفاوضات
مع واشنطن اول تعليق لوالدي سلمى بهجت بعد
الحكم باعدام قاتلها واعتقال عراقيين هدد
طليقته بنشر صور خاصه لها هذه الاخبار
وغيره نقولها لكم من قناه العربيه اهلا
بكم
في صحف الغربيه
بين مستشار الرئيس الامريكي للامن القومي
بعد اربع جلسات بدات في سبتمبر الماضي قضت
محكمه الزقازيق المصريه باعدام الطالب
اسلام محمد فتحي شنقا عقب ادانته بقتل
زميلته في الجامعه سلمى بهجت والمعروفه
الاعلاميه بطالبه الاعلام مع سبق الاصرار
والترصد وسائل الاعلام افادت بان جلسه
النطق بالحكم شهدت حضور المتهم وعائله
الضحيه الا ان والدها قال انه لن يرتاح
حتى يتم اعدام قاتل ابنته في ما كان
الجاني قد انهى حياه المجني عليها بعد ما
سدد لها ثلاث وثلاثين طعنه نافذه في انحاء
متفرقه بالجسد شهر اغسطس الماضي
وفي حادثه اخرى اثار الضجه واسعه اعتقل
قوات اعتقلت قوات الامن العراقيه شخصا هدد
طليقته بنشر صورها الخاصه على مواقع
التواصل ما لم تدفع له مبلغ مالي انا
مديريه مكافحه الجرائم في بغداد اوضح حتى
في بيان لها ان هذا التحرك جاء بعد ان
يستنجدت المشتكيه بمفرز المديريه بعد
تعرضها لابتزازا الكترونيا من قبل طليقها
مشيره الى ان عمليه القبض عليه تمت بعد ما
نصبت له الشرطه كمينا محكما بالتنسيق مع
سيده الضحيه واضافت المديريه ان المتهم
اعترف بجريمته بعد التحقيق معه
ما زال الحديث عن شركه تويتر وما يدور
داخلها يتصدر المشهد في السوشيال ميديا
ووسائل الاعلام خصوصا بعد التسريح نحو نصف
موظفها لكن اللافت في الامر ان الشركه
بدات في التواصل مع عشرات الموظفين الذين
تم طردهم وتدعوهم للعوده وكاله وبلومبرجر
نقلت عن مصادر قولها ان بعض الذين طلب
منهم العوده تم تسريحهم عن طريق الخطا
مشيره الى ان التخلي عنهم تم قبل ان تدرك
الاداره ان عملهم وخبراتهم قد تكون ضروريه
لبناء الميزات الجديده التي تصورها المالك
الجديد
وفي خبرنا الاخير كشف التقارير ان الشركات
ابل تتوقعوا ايا انخفضه انتاج ايفون 14
بنحوي ثلاثه ملايين هاتف خلال العام
الحالي مشيره الى ان الشركه وموردها
يهدفون الان لتصنيع 77 مليون جهاز مقارنه
ب 90 مليون في وقت سابق وكاله اوضحت ان
هذا الانخفاض في الانتاج يعود الى الطلب
الضعيف على طرازي ايفون وايفون 14 بلس
اضافه الى وجود مشاكل الامداد في مدينه
الصينيه والتي تعد ما قارا رئيسا لتصنيع
ايفون حيث تخضع المدينه حاليا لقيود
الاغلاق لمده اسبوع بسبب انتشاره
[موسيقى]